[Musique]
voilà la troisième scène et l'espace
numérique expérimental de l'opéra
national de paris lancé en 2015
elle propose chaque mois une nouvelle
oeuvre numérique inspiré de l'opéra est
conçu en collaboration avec des artistes
de la scène contemporaine
en juin dernier la troisième scène
invités à découvrir les coulisses du
tournage du film de longs discours dans
vos cheveux qui a eu lieu durant trois
nuits dans le célèbre palais garnier
un film qui raconte le parcours de deux
figurants du spectacle
tristan et isolde dans les couloirs et
les sous sols de l'opéra garnier à la
recherche du fameux lac caché je ne vous
en dis pas plus et je vous laisse elle
ces quelques images qui j'espère vous
donneront envie d'aller voir ce court
métrage de longs discours dans vos
cheveux
[Musique]
quittez la frénésie de paris aller sous
terre changer d'air dans les sous-sols
et découvrir dans les coulisses l'envers
du décor les décors de scène les cordes
etc aurait maquillé costume et lever de
rideau pour une scène de cap il était
caché dans l'opéra garnier
un autre temps tant que créatif en
pleine nuit tout le monde s'active
plutôt que de dormir silence ils
arrivent les personnages mythiques les
personnages archéologiques la troisième
scène scène virtuelle mécène quand même
qui s'immisce dans les palais et les
foyers pour partager les chants danses
et lumière des led aux chandelles de la
bête à la belle au regard de leurs
quatre danseuses immortel dans les
fleurs précieuse attend de la relève
mécanisme électrique des siècles de
techniques pour lutter contre l'ennui et
nuit blanche condamné à rêver de cheval
blanc
la main outils préhistoriques active le
clavier numérique montre la piste
suivant ce dédale et focus en terre
d'inconnus six pieds sous terre des
stèles
[Musique]
bon
obama
[Musique]
oh
non
là
là et je m'enfonce toujours plus bas
auprès de lui
[Musique]
or
oh
[Musique]
archéologie mais bon pourquoi rassuré
sur ses études c'est l'os
dans l'équipe des homos
[Musique]
oh